.
- L'Allemagne, le coeur
est déchirée.
♪ ♪ ♪
en grande partie de fonctionner,
sera-t-il coupé? Doit-on cesser
d'en importer?
l'entreprise familiale
de Arnold Mergell transforme
des produits chimiques
L'un de ces mélanges
est utilisé sur les voitures
pour éviter la corrosion.
des véhicules sur le marché
européen.
ces machines créent de la vapeur
à environ 280 degrés Celsius.
Le tout est alimenté par du gaz
Pour se défcececececette
dépendance, Arnold Mergell
mise sur l
mais la transition prendra
encore quelques années.
Si le gaz est si important
dans cette usine, comme dans
le pays, c'est entre autres
en raison des ch p p p p pris
l'Allemagne quant à ses sources
d'énergie.
dadadadadadance causée
par des choix économiques,
mais qui s'explique aussi
et diplomatiques.OMOMOMOMOMOMAS,
Centre énergie Jacques Delors
- Les Allemands sont devenus
devenir dépendants du gaz russe
dans l'espoir que cette
interdépendance germano-russe
permette un changement
de la politiieieieieieieieieieie
plus pacifique et coopératrice.
Et évidemment, depuis
le 24 février et l'agression
mili
contre la nation ukrainienne,
rererererererement que cette
politique allemande a échoué.
- Une approche défendue
la chancelière Angela Merkel.
Mais c'est d'abord à son
prédécesseur, Gerhard Schroder,.
Ce politicien est critiqué
pour sa proximité avec Moscou,
siégeant encore aujourd'huidmdmn
d'entreprises énergétiques
russes.
- Donc, même quand Mario t t t r
sous les bombes...
sous les bombes de Poutine,
Gerhard Schroder ce e e e e e e,
que j'imagine fort généreux,
et du coup à être rémunéré
par les entreprises d'État
et des entrururururururururururs
et loyaux services.
- Dès le début de la guerre
en Ukraine, un changement
d'
Le nouveau chancelier,z,z,z,z,a
suspension de la certification
un immense projet qui devaitdedt
de gaz russe acheminé
Le gaz russe continue néanmoinr
sur le territoire allemand.
ressource représente maintenant
35 % des importations du pays.
♪ ♪ ♪enenenenenenenenenenenenenr
entièrement, il faudra ê
patient. Berlin évoque
la mi-2024. Pour y arronononono,
le long du fleuve
dans l'ouest du pays.
Le port de Brunsl'l'l'l'l'l'l'ls
pour accueilelelelelelelelelel
liquéfié.
(bêleme
Le but : rempla
venu de Russie par du gaz
norvégien ou qetetetetetetetetea
fait des ann
Cet élu explique que celafafafe
pour ce projet, qui profitera à
la région, et aieseseseseseseses
d'énergie diversifiées.
Or, le gouvernement fédéral
ne s'est jamais montré intéressé
Il aura fallu la guerreurururue
enfin. Le port gazier devrait
Dès l'an prochain, des terminaux
flottants devraient être
installés pour commencer
l'approvisionnement.
Le maire de la ville aurait
aussi préf
soit autorisé avant, en temps
de paix, plutôt que d'être
précipité à cause de la guerre,
mais il se réjouit qu'enfin, a n
à la crise énergétique
qui mine le pays.
D l l l l l l l l l l l le gaz
et surtout son prix s'imposent
rapidement. C'est le cas
dans ce restaurant.
La cuisinière, le chauffage :
le gaz est à la base de tout
dans cet établissement.
Pour le propriétaire, le constat
est clair : l'énergie venue
de Russie, c'est fini.
Mais avec les risques
de récession, combien coûtera
cette décision?a a a a a a a a .
S'il s'oppose à un embargo
immédiat, l'industriel
Arnold Mergell croit néanmoins
que l'Allemagne finira
par franchir le pas.
♪ ♪ ♪
En plus de l'importation de gaz
naturel liquéfié, d'ici dix ans,
Berlin prévoit déjà de doubler
la part de solaire et d'éolien
dans sa production
d'électricité. Aujourd
grandement critiquée
pour sa dépendance à la Russie,
l'Allemagne pourrait bien tirer
des leçons de la tempête
qui souffle su
♪ ♪